let's go next to Lucas from
Massachusetts Lucas welcome to the show
what's on your mind today hey David
right now because I didn't get to um ask
my question last week but here's my
question please
so a lot of people are optimistic about
the war in Ukraine because of the
ukrainian's advances I'm not and here's
why okay I think that I worry that if
the GOP takes back Congress it will
block Ukraine funding and decide with
Putin what do you think I think they
almost certainly will now just as a
heads up you've got Discord
notifications blinging in the background
and that is a faux pas during the phone
call okay so if you can get those turned
off that would be really great I think
you were absolutely correct and when the
if Republicans get the opportunity to
stop the funding to Ukraine they will do
it
um under the guise of we have to take
care of America first that's what
they're saying and of course many people
will look at it and say this is another
way that you're playing soft with Putin
and they'll say it's not about playing
soft with Putin it's about we need to
deal with crime and immigration and all
these different things and of course we
can walk and chew gum at the same time
but yeah they will they will try to at
least cut funding to Ukraine and that's
the type of explanation that they'll
give all right thank you for ask
answering my question I've heard a lot
of different perspectives on it I'm glad
to hear yours all right Lucas thank you
very much
welcome all right there we go